يتحرك knacker in inter الآن
بأسرع ما يمكن لإحضار عائلة محلية إلى
هناك لحم خنزير مشوي
والأرز يخفف إغلاق بانكوك ، لكن
لا يزال بإمكان inter أن تكسب 30 دولارًا في اليوم
لتوصيل الطعام إلى الأشخاص العالقين في المنزل ،
إنه مال جيد ولكنه لا
يقارن بـ  ما اعتاد فعله
قبل 31 يومًا قبل أن يضرب الوباء تايلاند يدخل
الراتب اليومي كان أقرب إلى 300 دولارًا أمريكيًا هو
طيار تجاري لهواء الأسد التايلاندي
ليكون قرصانًا هو طريقنا في حلمي عندما
كنت خياري قضيت أكثر من 15
عامًا لتحقيقه  أحلم بأن أكون طيارًا ،
لقد سافرت كثيرًا في جميع أنحاء العالم ، أرى
ركابهم يبتسمون عندما أرتدي
ملابسي وأذهب إلى المطار ،
كل شيء يمكنني كسب بعض المال
لدعم عائلتي عندما
جلس الوباء لأول مرة في الحكومة التايلاندية المحظورة
معظم الدول الدولية  الرحلات الجوية
تعرضت حركة المرور المحلية لضربة كبيرة أيضًا بسبب
الإغلاق في البلاد ، حيث قال الطيارون
مثله إن دخلهم انخفض بنسبة 70٪
لم يتم تسريحه هو وأصدقاؤه ،
لكن رواتبهم تستند إلى  في
مهام رحلاتهم وتلك التي جفت
بسرعة ولكن اكتشف فيما بينهم أن هناك
الكثير من العمل المتاح من خلال
تطبيقات التوصيل ، كل ما عليه فعله الآن هو
تسجيل الدخول والاستعداد للمغادرة بمجرد وصول
الطلب ، اعتقدت أنني
مجرد جلوس هناك في انتظار  أي مساعدة
يجب أن أقاتل من أجل عائلتي ،
يجب أن أفعل شيئًا
مثل يدي مثل
الأشخاص الآخرين ، لدي دراجتي النارية ، نعم ،
يجب أن أعمل
معجبي البليت الذين يعملون لتوصيل الطعام
وقبل أن يصبح  طيارًا
دعاني لتجربة هذه الوظيفة في المرة الأولى التي حصلت
فيها على الطلب وأسلم إلى
العميل الشعور رائعًا وأنا فخور بي أن
الرحلات الجوية في تايلاند قد تنتعش ببطء
عندما تنتهي حالة الطوارئ ولكن
السياحة هي أحد المساهمين الرئيسيين  لحركة الطيران
وليس من الواضح متى
سيعود ذلك إلى طبيعته ،
يحاول inter أن يكون واقعيًا جدًا
بشأن
موعد استعادة جدول رحلته المعتاد ، أعتقد أن الجميع حصل على
ملحمة من الكودايين 19 ، كل شخص في
العالم  لكن انظر إلى الشخص الذي يقع
بجانبك في حالة حب ولكن
عليك أن تقاتل من أجلهم
، وأعتقد أن كوبي 19 لا يمضي وقتًا طويلاً
في العالم ، ابحث عن أي وظيفة تريدها أو
تحبها أو ترغب فيها  للقيام بذلك فقط ابدأ في
القيام بذلك إذا كان بإمكاني القيام بذلك ، يمكنك فعل ذلك